probably the most intense friendly fire
so far from Republicans was delivered
upon president Donald Trump by
Republican senators bob corker and Jeff
Flake yesterday and I'm gonna get into
Jeff Flake in a second
starting with bob corker bob corker said
both that President Donald Trump is
debasing our country and implied that
Trump should be in some kind of adult
daycare facility which I don't really
find either comment particularly
controversial really both are quite
realistic these are five tweets from
Donald Trump
slamming corker for his opposition to
the Republican tax cut plan Trump going
nuclear on one of his unhinged Twitter
tirades five tweets in a row and I'll
read them all together for you Donald
Trump starting with bob Corker who
helped President Obama give us the bad
Iran deal why is deal capital
capitalized I don't know and couldn't
get elected dog catcher in Tennessee is
now fighting tax cuts tax cuts also
capitalized why we might never know
corker dropped out of the race in
Tennessee when I refused to endorse him
and now is only negative on anything
Trump look at his record isn't it sad
that lightweight senator bob Corker who
couldn't get reelected in the great
state capitalized why we don't know of
Tennessee will now fight capitalized we
don't know why tax cuts plus senator
corker is the incompetent head of the
Foreign Relations Committee and look how
poorly the US has done he doesn't have a
clue as the entire world capitalized we
don't know why was laughing and taking
advantage of us
people like little bob corker have set
the u.s. way back now we move forward
what's with this entire little thing
spelling little li DD le that Donald
Trump does I don't know if he thinks
it's clever or cute or incisive or what
but it's weird and bob corker responded
to Donald Trump's unhinged Twitter rant
rant with a tweet of his own where he
said same untruths from an utterly
untruthful president hashtag alert the
day care staff and then corker was
interviewed by CNN's Manu Raju and went
even further
again a Republican slamming Republican
President Donald Trump I mean four times
he encouraged me to run and he told me
he went divorce me so I don't know it's
it's amazing unfortunately I think world
leaders are very aware that much of what
he says is untrue certainly people here
are because these things are provably
untrue I mean just they're just
factually incorrect and people know the
difference so I don't know why lowers
himself to such a low low standard and
the basis our country in the way that he
does but he does he bases our country
and this is making headlines because
it's a Republican right noting that bob
Corker said is remotely controversial or
deniable and corporate media is calling
this a blistering or scathing criticism
of Trump it's a pretty simple and non
inflammatory and obvious criticism of
Trump given the circumstances but
because it's a Republican it's making
big headlines and the truth is that
corker doesn't have much to lose at this
point he's retiring he's not running for
re-election and he's saying that he
won't support Trump for election again
that's all fine and good but everybody
who supported Trump to begin with should
be absolutely ashamed of themselves
because that's why we're in this
situation to begin with and bob Corker
should be criticized not criticizing not
only Donald Trump himself what about the
80% of the Republican Party that still
supports Donald Trump what about them
they are as much a part of the problem
as Donald Trump himself and if Trump is
debasing the country then you have to
blame the Republicans who put Trump in
the Oval Office to begin with
could this be the start of a Republican
deluge against Donald Trump well maybe
we'll get to Jeff Flake in a second
someone wrote to me hey David Robert
Muller must be getting really close to
Trump in that investigation because
Trump is particularly easily triggered
right now I don't really know if that's
true Trump has been unable to avoid
taking the bait from anybody writes
minor voices on the Internet
all the way up to major political
players in both the Democratic and
Republican parties I don't think there's
any diff
anything different right now about how
easily Trump is being triggered bob
Corker number one and who is number two
let's talk about Jeff Flake in the
possible growing Republican civil war
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership